how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and today we have some new eternals
leaks to go over and with these leaks we
have a better look at some of the
eternals than we've ever had before
and we even have a description of icarus
and they talk a little bit about his
powers too
and we get a tiny glimpse of some of the
other eternals as costumes as well
so we'll dive right into this but if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest mcu
news
now this leak is actually coming from
marvel themselves because we have a
leaked photo of the back of a box of a
marvel legend series collectible
of icarus and some of the other eternals
as well and as we can see here on the
back of this box we have a great look at
marvel's icarus the costume looks
fantastic the design and the colors look
absolutely incredible and he looks very
royal he looks like an
eternal and like i said there is a
description of him on the box and it
says
moral kind and charismatic icarus boasts
of incredible strength
flight and the ability to project cosmic
energy beams from his
eyes now he also has superhuman strength
so he's a little bit like superman here
and homelander so we could get some
superman vibes from icarus in the movie
because after all these characters the
eternals are immortal and basically gods
but at the bottom of this box we
actually find out a little bit more
about the plot of the film
in the bottom it actually tells us a
little bit about gilglamesh and it says
the strongest and kindest eternal
gilgamesh becomes thena's de facto
partner when the events of the past
exile them from their other eternals now
there have been plot leaks and there
have been rumors in the past suggesting
that thena has a very big secret
and it appears that that is true as tina
has been exiled most likely due to that
secret
now what most of us assume this secret
is is the fact that she has a child
perhaps she has a child with a deviant
which is forbidden
this could be the case and perhaps
gilgamesh actually knew about this
since he is the kindest eternal perhaps
athena could have went to him for some
comfort and support and some advice on
what to do
and again since he's the kindest he
probably wouldn't have ratted her out so
when the rest of the eternals found out
about theena's secret they knew that he
knew as well
and had to banish them both now in the
same plot leak that talks about this
it says that sprite goes and finds
gilgalmesh and gets him to come back
however it didn't mention anything about
athena but if the eternals are going to
take on
the deviants and other villains as well
they are going to need theena because
she is their greatest warrior so we know
that she's going to come back at one
point in time but still the question
remains since we've heard this
who is her son and the biggest theory
and i guess the biggest question as well
is could it be thanos now we know that
in the comics
thanos is actually born to two eternals
alars and sui-san
neither were deviants but thanos did get
the deviant gene now they would have to
change the origin just a little bit
which the mcu does frequently
but perhaps in the mcu thanos mother is
an eternal but his father
is a deviant because that's who then got
with now remember the eternals film is
going to be spanning
thousands and thousands of years of the
marvel cinematic universe's history
and kevin feige did say that the
eternals will address what they were
doing
during the events of infinity war and
end game which of course revolve around
thanos so they're clearly
going to address the fact that thanos's
parents at least in the comics were
eternals and he has a clear connection
to them
plus thanos is a deviant and the
deviants are going to be in the eternals
film as well
now marvel studios president kevin feige
did recently announce
that marvel studios is going to be doing
a special presentation on billy billy
giving us a glimpse of what the 2021
marvel slate is going to bring us this
could bring us the first look for the
eternals
we know that marvel studios actually
already showed a first look of the
eternals at ccxp
with some unfinished footage well that
was over
a year ago and the eternals has been
done with their filming for a very long
time now and editing is definitely done
so right now they are just sitting on
the eternals trailer and it looks like
they could be releasing it
on new year's eve and if it does happen
for those of you who are wondering how
to watch it don't worry marvel studios
always puts their trailers
right on youtube immediately after that
recently happened on investor day for
disney they released a ton of new
trailers and marvel studios immediately
put them up on their youtube channel
right after
and of course i'll be posting them on my
youtube channel as well so be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest trailers that are supposed
to come
let me know who you think thena sun is
in the comments down below
do you think it's thanos let me know
down below don't forget to like the
video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof